Uh, so thank you guys for joining
us. For our first Google talks,
a Ad in the Birmingham
office. Uh, I want to, um,
I have the great pleasure today
to introduce Bridget Russo,
the Cmo of Shinola before I do,
for those of you who don't
have a deep background, uh, uh,
on the company itself, I wanted
to give you a little bit, um,
it was conceived in 2011.
So when we think about our own brand,
Shinola is only about five years old.
Um,
it is the maker of modern handcraft
watches, bicycles, leather goods,
journals,
and pet accessories,
of which it sounds like they're
expanding into even more products.
So we'll hear from Bridget about that.
Um, they're really focused on, and again,
you think about those of you who
work in the automotive industry,
some of the importance of
handcrafting leather. Um,
some of the more upscaled ways
that we try and convey a, um,
important elements of our
auto manufacturers background.
A lot of that is in the messages
that Shinola brings into the market.
So really interesting there.
Um, as far as their locations,
uh, those you'd be probably know they're
headquartered here in Detroit, um,
in the college for
creative studies building,
which was a former re
automotive, uh, research lab. Um,
and then since the company's founding,
uh,
they have I think about seven stores
now that they've opened up. Um,
as Bridget herself.
A little bit of background on Bridget,
her background started in PR,
which is coming in handy.
Obviously as a CMO you have
to deal with a lot of things,
particularly in social media nowadays.
Um, with her background in PR,
she started on the agency side,
very familiar to some of you and then
moved over onto the client side working,
um, with diesel and the fashion
industry. Uh, from there she moved in,
um, started to work with Eden,
which is a company that, um,
final started with his wife to support,
um,
some of the team to drive
industry in a, in Africa. Um,
and that moved her into her
own consultancy, which is
a lot of our Googlers do,
uh,
is to start their own businesses.
And from there it led her to Shinola
and two from New York to Detroit.
And so with that, um, we welcome
her and want to hear her story and,
and learn about a bit more about Shinola.
So with that, I'll fucking bridge it.
[inaudible]
um,
well thank you for taking the time out
of your day to hear the Shinola story.
Um, can you, can everybody hear me
okay? Yeah, that's okay. Yeah. Cool. Um,
so I'm going to take you through quickly
since we do have the fireside chat and
I don't do want to give you guys the
opportunity to ask questions afterwards.
So I'll kind of whizzed
through this a little bit,
give you a little background as to why
we started the company and what's up next
in terms of new categories.
Um,
so we started with building a watch
factory in Detroit back in 2011.
People thought our founder Tom
Card service was crazy. Uh,
why not accept that manufacturing
has gone from this country?
Why not let the rest and weeds
finish what they started?
Why not just embrace the
era of disposability and
why didn't we buy a warmer
coat before we moved to,
there were three Detroit winters.
We've asked ourselves these questions
and work not to find our answers,
but to build it. So really, you know,
from the beginning the intention was
always to not only be in a city where
manufacturing was in its in
its history and its lifeblood,
but also to be in a city where we could
have a positive impact on the community
in our case,
and creating jobs.
Um,
here's a little video.
So this is
where it all began.
Yeah, the question isn't why you
build a watch factory in Detroit.
It's why you built one anywhere else.
This is the city that made this
country with its steel, with its skill,
with a slight reestablish some trays that
hadn't been seen in this country in a
generation or more.
It's a tall order to return to full,
but it's what hundreds
of Shinola employees work
towards every day here in Troy
where we believe in the beauty of
industry, the glory of manufacturer.
I know where American is mate.
So it started with watches.
Uh,
we launched our first product in 2013.
the factory opened in 2012, which is
when I started with the company, uh,
alongside watches. We also had
bicycles, leather goods, journals.
Um, but really our messaging from the
beginning was watches built in Detroit,
um, of quality. And so we started,
there are first watch was the run.
Well,
um,
if you guys were around at that time
paying attention to some of the marketing.
Um, we had launched the Runwell watch
before we actually had product and market.
So that was March, 2013. Um,
the previous year we had a brand website
up where we were speaking directly to
the consumer through social,
primarily at the time,
Twitter and Facebook and really telling
people about our story directly,
not going through the trades and
sort of the normal, uh, you know,
where you would launch a brand showing
product before it was finished sewing
swatches of leather,
talking about our relationship with the
college for creative studies where we're
based, uh, to the degree that some
people were confused as to what we were,
you know, they would be like, are you a
watch company? Are you a bike company?
Are you a school?
Um,
but that really helped lead us
to the launch of the Runwell.
Fast forward to march of 2013,
um,
we had about 10,000 people on our email
list at that point and about the same
number of followers on Facebook and
Twitter. And we launched the watch.
We hadn't actually made the watch yet.
$550 price point.
We had 2,500 units by
the end of that week.
So eight days we sold out of the
watch. Um, which was pretty incredible.
We really didn't know in the beginning
there was some thought that Shinola would
actually be more of a company to
make watches for other brands.
But then when we saw the strength of
the run well and the Shinola brand,
we decided to go full force.
Subsequently, we've launched these other,
what we call platforms and
most recently the Canfield,
which is a refined Runwell bicycles.
So bicycles going back to the 80s,
really that production went off shore.
The U s primarily, um, you know,
the, one of the biggest
names, Schwinn, uh,
you might know the brand still out there,
but it's not owned by the family anymore.
They were one of the last to move
their manufacturing overseas.
So they lost the right,
it was sold the rights to their name,
but they did hold on to one piece of
their business called Waterford precision
cycles.
So they were making custom bicycles,
$10,000 and up that people
would wait months for.
So we met sky Yeager.
How we approach all of our categories
is really finding leaders within that
category. So in the case of
bikes that was sky, um, sky said,
I know the guy we need to go to.
Richard Schwinn up there in the corner
is a great grandson of the man who
started a Schwinn bicycles.
And we approached them and said,
what would it take for you to make
bicycles for Shinola? And we said,
we'll probably make about a thousand a
year and is I need to hire more people.
So we're like, great, right in line with
our, with our messaging. So, you know,
some people ask, well, why are the
bikes so pricey? Runwell is $3,000.
The Bixby that you see,
there's $2,000,
and it's because of the quality and the
craftsmanship that goes into it. Um,
so we make the frame and
fork with Waterford, uh, and
then we assemble the bikes.
As you see there in our Detroit
store paper, we work with,
um,
a bindery in Ann Arbor or
close to Ann Arbor, um,
called, um, Malloy brothers, sorry,
brain fart there for a minute.
Um, and again, we really saw the
market. So with all of our categories,
we really look at them in two ways as
brand builders or as volume drivers.
So bicycles,
leather and soon to be audio,
which I'll tell you about in a little
bit. Um, are really the volume drivers.
And then things like the journals,
bicycles,
pet accessories are the brand builders.
They're equally as important,
but it really helps us not only kind of,
um,
continue to provide products that are
relevant to the lifestyle of our consumer,
but also to add a point of
difference in the marketplace.
So if you go into a Neiman's or
Nordstrom in the watch department,
you might see a Shinola bike hanging.
Um,
we actually made all of the buyers of
the big department stores come to Detroit
before they wanted to buy the line.
Um,
so that definitely was helpful in
helping them show the full breadth of the
brand in their stores.
Leather,
we recently signed on a few years
ago now, uh, John and Richard,
they had a brand called Lambertson
and true x that we did very well. Um,
they're highly regarded
in the fashion industry.
Then they moved on to Tiffany's where
they built their leather business to a $50
million business.
And we're kind of in semi retirement when
we approached them to run our leather
business. So we started with small leather
goods and have expanded now into bags,
wallets, belts, um, come this fall.
We're really have a full
representation for women. Um, so again,
looking at leaders
within the categories to,
to lead the design and production
and then pet accessories. So these are
these fun categories, just as much work.
Um, but ones that really help create the
buzz around the brand because it's not
every day that you launch a new watch
or a new bicycle or a new range of
journals, but this is an opportunity
to get that PR earned media value
and then the marketing.
So it all started,
this was the ad that we ran
going back March, 2013. Um,
we at first we weren't going
to advertise. We were like, no,
we're not that kind of brand.
We're not going to do it. Um,
right about when I came on board,
we hired an agency called partners
and spade based out of New York.
They really helped us, um, design
the next version of the site,
which is pretty much what you see today
and really put a stake in the ground
around Detroit.
Built watches a quality.
And we,
we decided to take this ad out and we
ran it in the New York Times, USA Today,
Detroit free press in the
Wall Street Journal, um,
sort of mid week in the
process of selling the watch.
And by the time the New York Times
Sunday Times style ran on Sunday,
they were sold out already.
Hm.
Um, you might remember this when Detroit
announced bankruptcy a few days later,
we ran this in the New York Times to
those who have written off Detroit.
We give you the Birdie.
Birdie happened to be a watch that
we were releasing at that same time.
And again, the P PR value
on this was amazing. Um,
and again, you know, for me, uh, if
you guys are familiar with PR newswire,
that's where you would
put your press releases.
I really saw the New York
Times as our PR newswire.
I found that when you had something
relevant that was had culturally relevant
impact,
um,
the New York Times was a great vehicle
when it came to mother's Day and father's
Day. And we were just announcing
the run well on a different color.
That was probably not the best ROI to
run a full page ad in the New York Times.
Yeah.
And then the second year we worked
with Bruce Weber. So Bruce Weber,
you guys might know a famous
fashion photographer. Um,
I like to say the first year we showed
people what was behind our doors,
highlighting the people that work in the
factory and establishing ourselves as a
leader within the industry. And then
the next year with our work with Bruce,
we really,
it was a love letter to
Detroit celebrating the people
outside of our doors and
why we came to Detroit in the first place.
Yeah.
Um, last year you might remember the
launch in April of the Apple Watch,
uh, call the agency, I think
a week before and said, hey,
can you guys come up with something
that would kind of just, you know,
get us in the conversation
of this major launch.
And so they came up with this a watch,
so smart that it can tell you the
time just by looking at it run well,
just smart enough. Um, so we
ran these ads again, you know,
sprinkle here and there.
Wall Street Journal,
New York Times ran some digital
around it too. And again,
the buzz that we created off of it was
really tremendous. Um, in a time when,
and we, we all know how much
apple spends on advertising.
So at a few friends that work there,
and I got a text from one saying cheeky,
which it was. And then this year, um,
in an election year, we knew jobs
was going to be a hot topic. Um,
and we really wanted to celebrate the
fact that we created over 500 jobs since
we launched.
And so we came out with this campaign.
There's a funny thing that happens when
you build factories in this country.
It's called jobs. And again,
really highlighting the
people behind the products.
We are a true manufacturing company
built not by the things we make,
but by the people who make them.
Um,
this year in the past we were,
um,
primarily our media plan was primarily
print and we started to see some
diminishing returns,
I would say mid last year.
So we really did a shift towards digital
this year working with premium partners
like Vanity Fair, l Harper's
bizarre vice to create content. Um,
so some of that you guys might have seen,
um,
we'll continue with that for a second
half of the year around big product
launches. So continuing to talk
about our leather, our watches,
and expand our reach outside
of our immediate consumers.
Uh, our big push for second half of
the year we'll be around women's.
The challenge that we do have is
that talking about jobs is great,
but when you're trying to sell a hobo bag,
talking about jobs,
it doesn't really help. It
doesn't mean that, you know,
women don't care about creating jobs,
but when you're trying to sell
someone this great leather bag,
that messaging doesn't
always link up together.
So that's something that we're
working through now to understand.
Probably around September
around the debates,
the jobs messaging will come up again,
but then we'll make a shift towards
really focusing on celebrating our women's
product and, and showing people
that we're serious about our,
our women's products
retail.
So our retail environments are really,
in my view, part of our marketing.
Um, we look at them as living,
breathing things there.
They're not museums for products,
but really community spaces.
So we activate our stores quite
frequently, two to three times a month.
Um, we not only throw our own events,
but we opened them up to the community.
So the local Pr Association might hold
their annual meeting in the morning.
Uh, we, we work with creative mornings
to hold talks in our stores. Uh,
we're currently working with a local
barber shop in Detroit called Social Club
too.
They do a series called shoptalk where
they actually cut people's hair while
they're participating in a talk.
It sounds weird, but it works.
If anybody has attended there,
they're pretty interesting.
So we're doing that, uh,
not only in Detroit and Ann Arbor,
but across cities, DC, New York, La,
um, and each door is really
unique. Taking on the personality,
not only of the building that we're in,
but also the city that we're in.
And there's a few. We're
now at 15, 16 stores.
By the end of this year we'll have 20
and aim to open eight to 10 every year.
What's next? The fun part. Audio.
So come October, November,
we'll start with turntables.
Working with this gentlemen,
gentlemen here. Alex Rawson,
who again is a leader within the category.
He started a headphone brand that he's
got on right? They're called Odyssey.
It looks like he has waffles on his ears,
but a highly regarded within the
audio file community. So again,
we saw an opportunity, if you
look at what beats did, um,
beats charges a lot of money for a
product that doesn't really warrant that
price point.
And everyone you walk around and you see
I'm sure by people in the office might
have a beats headphones,
but our audio file friends tell us
that it is not of the quality that that
should be for the price point we,
so we saw an opportunity to bring value
into the category with good design and
audio file quality and then jewelry. So a,
some of you may recognize Pamela Love.
Uh, she's a designer out of New York.
We're partnering with her to launch
jewelry come mid October. Uh,
this will be part of a larger
Shinola women's launch.
So not only jewelry but expanding our
watch offering a and a new collection
called Gomelsky. We do have a
style right now called Gomelsky,
but this is sort of an offshoot of that.
And this is one of my favorite
films that we did with Bruce Weber.
You know what? Um, I think that
when it comes to to Detroit,
I view it just how I view love.
Like I feel like in everything
you have like a soulmate, right?
If I had to just give like one
line about the city of Detroit,
I would most definitely say
that. Uh, I belong here.
Native is definitely a soul mate of mine.
I was working on his poem a few days ago.
It's about the city of Detroit,
but it's how it breeds like
great, great guest, grandkids,
great boys, great girls. How we
grow up to be great men and women.
I don't want it to read it
to you. Okay, that's fine.
Somewhere in the projects there's a kid
working on a project to project to the
world. He lives in a city that grows
boys and girls into lions and tigers.
The city, it takes the fire in
the ashes, bills, rebuilds, turns,
abandoned houses,
empty fields and to things.
We're looking at a place that never
looks back the center stage of a nation,
the heartbeat, the patients, the music,
the Motown, the midtown and downtown.
The always come back around and we
fight for reputation, walk, ride bikes.
Our destination practice.
Patient knows they can't forget about
this [inaudible] the city that continues
to call the world's bluff somewhere.
There's a kid working on a project to
project from a city that's rebuilding,
that we built in from the ashes together.
So the everywhere there can be Detroit
gamblers,
they
[inaudible].
Yeah, that was really powerful.
You can see why you like it now.
Two years old. And I think still totally
relevant. Yeah. So you mentioned,
I've heard you say in
some of your discussions,
this idea of conscious consumerism and
how a brand is basically responsible for
being a really good brand. And so
when you look at some of this, um,
and you can see how you're investing in
having the best people build the brands
that you want, the product you want to
present. Can you talk a little bit about,
yeah,
so it's,
it's a concept that I was first
introduced to when working for [inaudible]
Urbano anally back in 2004 when
we launched the brand Eden.
And they were really pioneers in the
space, especially in fashion. The idea of,
you know, conscious fashion people
didn't understand, you know,
the green movement was happening.
There was some organic brands out
there and none of them were all that
fashionable.
Um,
so this idea that you could
have quality product out there,
but by the nature of
your business practices,
your production practices who were also
helping to build communities and have a
positive impact,
um,
coming from the fashion industry where
you never talked about your production in
part because you didn't want to let
your competitors know where you were
manufacturing. But also, you know,
now we know so many things
have happened since then.
You guys probably weren't even born yet.
Kathy Lee, Gifford, Nike and every step,
everything subsequently that happened
from there. It wasn't pretty, you know,
the fashion industry,
um,
can be a pretty ugly industry or has
been in the past. Not intentionally.
I think as things went offshore that
control and understanding how things were
being manufactured in other places,
they weren't up to the same standards
as the US. Um, so, you know,
a lot of people early on got burned.
I don't think Nike set out intentionally,
you know,
to have children making their clothes.
But unfortunately it's hard to have
that control when you're doing things
overseas. A lot has changed. Um,
but this idea of buying products and
supporting products that have a positive
impact, whether that's on the environment,
whether that's on the community.
I think now for millennials
and anyone that's under 30,
I think that's a big part of that
purchase decision. Um, you know,
certainly is for me,
I'm not under 30,
but you know,
it,
I think if all other things are equal,
I'm willing to pay a little bit more to
know that this product is having some
sort of positive impact.
At the end of the day,
it still has to be strong product and
we'll learn that Eden the hard way,
you know,
we really put the mission in front of the
brand and butter product second and at
Shinola, what I really loved
when I met them, I was like, wow,
this product is amazing.
The fact that, you know,
we were creating jobs to
me was the cherry on top,
but that product needs
to stand on its own.
Yeah. Do you see that as being, uh,
increasingly challenging as the demand
for the product increases and the scale
and the volume that you need to
fulfill that demand increases?
As we think of other brands
who have, maybe you mentioned
even Nike in this case.
Do you see that as a
challenge for Shinola? No.
As you,
as you grow,
and we really look at
everything we do from, you know,
in the beginning we looked at where to
source her shopping bags and we said,
well, we can source them in the
states but we and spend $12 on them.
Or we could take the savings of sourcing
that the bag overseas and put it
towards r and d to doing what we're doing
in Detroit and helping to grow that.
And since then we started with the
watch factory. I didn't mention,
but we opened a leather
factory two years ago, um,
where we're producing the majority of
our Leather Watch straps and some of our
small leather goods. So again,
continuing to add to that capacity.
The reality is we're in a global economy.
So every single component
is not made under one roof.
That hasn't existed for a
very long time. Um, you know,
we felt very strongly what we were doing.
We were doing more than assembly.
And so we use the word build.
You guys probably read that's got us
into a little hot water of recent,
but I think it's an opportunity,
um,
for us to work with the FTC on
clarifying for the consumer and makers of
products to say,
this isn't clear.
It's not clear for the consumer
and it's not clear, um,
for anyone who's trying to do business
and do the right thing in the u s um,
you know,
I can tell you from experience,
there's stuff out there that says
made in Italy, are made in France,
that is definitely not made there.
They might add a zipper at
the end or a small stitch. Um,
and their country allows them to say that
to preserve, you know, their industry,
what's left of it. So this is happening
across the board. Um, you know,
the one thing I can say, you know,
to anyone, please, we do do tours.
You're welcome to sign
yourself up for one. Um,
you walk through that factory and you
see the people that are most of them.
Detroiters,
it's hard to say that we're not having
a positive social impact. And I,
the most thing you know
about it is when you say,
try and suggest to these people that what
they're doing is an important or what
they're doing. I heard some comments
as people do on social media. Oh,
a monkey can do it. It's like putting
together Ikea furniture. First of all,
I'm challenged putting together,
I challenged putting anything,
but it is hard. Yeah. You know,
a watch is made up of these tiny little
parts and to suggest that assembly is
not as complicated or you know,
not an important job that takes
some level of skill. You know,
that's why we felt very
strongly around the word build.
Now we have to qualify that to,
to make sure it's clear that it's a
combination of us and imported parts.
Something that we were always transparent
about. When you look into her FII cues.
In fact, there was a question
is this American made?
And we answered that and have
done from the very beginning. Um,
but I think that as a brand and also
the FTC need to take this opportunity to
educate the consumer. Maybe there's
a, like with food, you know,
if you guys remember with food,
it was sort of the wild west and people
natural and organic and what did it all
mean? Well, now there are systems
in place and labeling in place.
Maybe we need to do the same thing
with consumer goods. Yeah. Well it's,
it's clear that you have made
an impact in Detroit, um,
beyond today's news over the
FTC. So, you know, how do you,
how does that,
it sounds like you've been trying to do
that regardless of what retail store you,
what location you open a retail
store, um, how does that,
how do you guys factor that in to where
you do open them up and how do you look
to embed yourself in the community?
Like I know Ethan,
the Saturday you have a local band
playing at the store in Detroit.
So tell us a little bit about
how you've continued to look at,
where are you open stores
and how important the you've,
you've made an impact.
You're trying to make an
impact in the local market.
I think for us, um, you know,
it's always a balance. Yeah. Um,
we recently got some investments so
we have a board of directors and so,
you know,
there's a responsibility we have now
to a group of people versus one person.
Um, but you were just actually
having this conversation today.
We're still a baby brands,
so there has to be that balance of brand
building and making sure that we're
still unique and special for people and
high touch and also getting the Roi and
getting us to profitability to make sure
that we're being responsible and also
growing a sustainable brand. Um, as far
as the community aspect is concerned,
we'll continue to look at our
manufacturing, not just in Detroit.
We're actually looking at
Chicago potentially for eyewear.
So parts of, of the, the manufacturing
that we can do in the states,
we will,
whether that's through our own facilities
or partnering with facilities that are
out there, um, you know, we're,
one of our leather partners potentially
could close because their rents going up
and they can't afford it.
So it's looking at that and saying
maybe we can put them together with,
um, manufacturers that we know
in Florida to combine efforts.
One is strong in high end handbags,
the other one has great process and back
of house, you know, how do you bring,
there's so much time and effort that
we put into these things to continue to
stand behind our goal, which
is to create American jobs. Um,
you know,
on a local level we go into markets
and really either it's working with an
agency or just going in on our own and
making those relationships with the local
community. So the local makers, uh,
different organizations that
are working on job creation, um,
and really embedding ourselves. In some
cases it might be as simple as, you know,
hosting an event for them in our store
or a fundraiser or donating a watch for
uh, an option. Um, but again,
making those relationships on a local
level as well. Yeah. And hopefully I'm,
you know,
as we start to grow and,
and really start to push
through tent pole initiatives,
I think the idea of workforce development
is something that we can be thought
leaders in.
So we're talking now on how do we,
whether it's partnering with Job Corps,
which was started in DC but has
local chapters across the US and really
help playing an active role in this
workforce development.
Because the reality is, uh,
and I was just starting to
educate myself on it. There's,
I think it's something like 2 million,
what they call middle
skill jobs out there. Uh,
so primarily trade manufacturing jobs
that there are no longer that generation
with that skillset.
So it's like a dying breed of artisans
and two things need to happen. One,
then there needs to be
infrastructure for the training,
but also a PR campaign to encourage
people to take these jobs.
Because it's a better job than
working at Mcdonald's or, um,
you know,
any of the big box stores.
And it's an opportunity to learn a
craft and work your way up. You know,
I, I, my mother owned a factory,
she started working in a factory in New
York and it put food on our table and
put me through school and
through college. So, um,
it is a career opportunity and we need
to kind of change the face of what these
jobs are. They're not dirty jobs. Yeah.
They're actually career paths
for every one is not, you know,
some people will go on and start their
own tech business or some people may
decide they want to be designers, but, um,
there's a lot of these jobs out there
and not the skilled labor force to take
them. And then we have the
unemployment rate. So, you know,
these things can be mutually beneficial.
So do you see that, was that a
premise at the start, do you think?
For the company I'm at the heart of,
it was job creation.
Um, or did it start as um, you
know, really, really strong, um,
wellmade products and then
the job creation thing,
cause it is a really interesting component
you mentioned you didn't actually
mention I think I wear is one of the
next areas that you're going to go into.
So you think about eyewear and how you
would now repeat this whole process of
finding the right partners and, and go
about selling it. So curious about it.
The job creation was always part of
the conversation alongside and making
quality products that were well
designed. And then we'll classic, um,
you know, from a business opportunity
standpoint, watches for instance,
so you have watches at the, you
know, the big old fashion watches.
So Michael Kors and brands such
as that at the three $5,500 range.
And then you have the high end luxury
watches, tag horror and the like.
And no one was really at our
price point offering the quality,
um, with the great brand
story behind it. Um,
so we saw a business opportunity as well.
Um, where we, Parker is a good example.
They saw a business opportunity and
they also have the social impact part of
their business, which if you notice
it's not front and center, um,
it's sort of behind the
scenes even more so now than,
than ever before when they first launched.
So I think ultimately it has to
start with good product. Yeah.
It has to be somewhat of a differentiator
in the marketplace and there has to be
a positive impact in some way,
shape or form,
whether it's double bottom line or triple
bottom line, which is hard to achieve.
But,
you know,
I think it's important now and in the
longterm it's just good business. Yeah.
So always back to that conscious
consumerism type thing.
So you weren't here at Google and data
is part of our world. We love data.
And so some of the, uh, the
marketing get samples, uh,
as the Cmo you've talked about,
um, uh, traditionally based, um,
and then a lot of the experiential things
you talked about in your retail stores,
very experientially based.
So can you talk to this group who
really looks at a lot of data, um,
and the campaigns and things that they do,
how you think about marketing and how you,
what kind of data you look at based on
the things that are important to you and
trying to reach these consumers. In the
beginning we didn't have data to look. We,
we had nothing to benchmark mark
it against. Now, you know,
going into our fourth year,
we do have that data and we are diving
into that data and actually working with
you guys as well as a group out of DC
called resonate to really hone in on,
okay,
we have this fan base here of
Shinola advocates and super fans.
We know there are like people out
there who don't even know we exist yet.
So how do we develop those personas and
then we're off first time ever believe
it or not doing programmatic.
Um,
so really looking at like individuals
out there and using a lot of digital to,
to reach them. Um, really
cutting back on print.
I'm a still a big fan on experiential.
I think at the end it's about the mix.
It's not like, oh, all digital is the
way to go, or all print is the way to go.
It's the mix because that's
how people live their lives.
That's how they're consuming media and
information. So it can't be all one way.
I think part of the success
early on is that, and again,
this is somewhat anecdotal, but
if people would tell me, Oh,
you guys are everywhere.
Well we weren't,
I had no way had a
budget to be everywhere,
but we were everywhere where they
were in the right moment. So you know,
and there was a lot of, you know, great
PR value there. So they saw the PR,
then they'd go online and you know,
see the social activity.
Then they'd go outside
and see the out of home.
It's how that mix all works together.
And then you have to be careful,
you know,
the data,
depending on how you look at it can drive
you in a direction that may not be the
right direction.
This is somewhat of a weird example,
but I'll give it to you anyway. So,
um, when I was working for Urbano,
he often told this story. Um,
there's an NGO that went into,
um,
a village in Kenya and the women were
walking like five miles to clean water
every day.
Uh,
and so they came in and they built a
well in the village and the women kept
walking the five miles. Well, no
one stopped to ask them, you know,
we're going to build a well, where
would you like us to put it? So finally,
after the fact, because they
were so puzzled, they asked,
why are you still walking five
miles? And they said, well said,
get away from the men.
That's our time together. No one
asked the question. So they were like,
what if we did it half way? And I'm like,
perfect. And that was a moment when too.
So we can't forget that
this data is great, but we're
all human beings, right?
And there's aspects to our behavior
that can't be put on a spreadsheet.
So the emotion and that
the high touch of a brand,
if you can maintain that some
in some way, shape or form. Um,
you know,
especially when you have limited dollars,
there has to be that element
of just human nature.
And then I don't know the answer for every
brand of what that is. And you know, I,
I still watch that video and think, well,
maybe we should run that in theaters,
you know, just because you don't even
know what the hell we're selling.
But I'm intrigued. I want to know more
about that brand after seeing that video.
Yeah.
So it is about the balance.
It's about the mix and
don't be so dictated by the
data that you lose the fact
that you are all human beings
and consumers as well. And that,
that gut feeling of, you know, what is
right and taking some calculated risks.
Yeah.
Uh,
I want to open it up for any questions
that you all might have that you'd like
to ask
Bridget. Go ahead. All right.
Thanks for coming. Good. First off,
I did not know anything
about the association with
the Schmidt family tied to
your bicycles,
but that seems to be a model in your
personality or an expert in
the field kind of help that.
Can you explain like the
process of identifying that
person that represents best
the shuttle a brand? Because I would
think it's more art than science. Yes.
To the data of like, is
it a relationship? Is it,
how do you identify that person that
represents how you want to launch a brand?
Um, we've been very lucky. Our
founder knows a lot of people. Uh,
and so it's a little bit of asking around.
I'm asking you advice from,
you know, friends. Uh,
and then some people would just somehow
cross our paths because, you know,
someone might know what we're up to
and say, I've got the person for you.
You need to talk to sky Yeager or
you need to talk to Alex. Rostin.
So it's been pretty organic
from that perspective.
And we've never done big searches.
I mean,
even we just named Tom Milan or CEO,
we didn't put the job out
there. We never did. Um,
but we just started to
put our feelers out.
Tom was working with us on
some side projects. And again,
it was that gut feeling that our founder
felt like this was the right guy, um,
to help lead the brand.
And so that,
that's kind of at least to date how
decisions are made around people in
particular. Um, and it
makes for a really, uh, uh,
Tom or founder refers to us
as the bar scene in star wars.
Um, and that, you know, we all come from,
from varied backgrounds,
but I think it's helpful in making,
keeping us on our toes and also
seeing different perspectives.
The fact that Tom Comes from,
you know,
the sports arena and coming from that
background I think is an interesting
perspective for,
you know,
we don't even like to call ourselves a
fashion brand with zero sells more as a
design brand. So I think having those
outside voices in the outside perspective,
because if you're all in a
room with the same, you know,
if we had just had a whole
bunch of fashion people,
we'd be doing things very
differently tonight. Yeah.
The questions got ahold
of a skilled trade thing.
I grew up down river written
all the high schools down there.
My parents generation has shop,
they had a actual working auto shop
within a high school and everything.
But then that generation,
it's such a stigma
how you feel,
especially with how deeply passionate
people like your sectors upper middle on
came from those families
that have the stigma.
How do you use that and where do
you start to try to remove it?
I mean is it started with
politicians start in the schools?
Does it start with the brain out cause
that you have re calibrating their
mindset and where to really start to
get rid of that trade school is under
achieving and you have to have before
your school because those jobs are kind of
skills do transcendent and Mary Lou.
Yeah, I think definitely education is one
piece. And working at the civil level,
just make sure that you have the support
locally in these cities because there
are certain cities like Detroit
that are more, um, you know,
sort of better poised to
really drive this, uh,
buffalo's another good city.
Um,
and also working with
partners in the media, um,
who have such control now to really shape
people's opinions one way or the other.
Um, to help tell this story. And you know,
especially now with things
like Etsy for instance,
I think it's coming back to where people
are interested in learning how to make
things on their own,
making things and selling them now with
a great platform that you can go direct
to consumer. Um, so it's good timing.
And I think now with kids coming
out of college with that degree,
that really expensive degree
and no guarantee of a job, zero.
You know,
so people are looking at different
ways of how they can build a career.
And it's not the traditional doctor,
lawyer,
not everyone can be an entrepreneur
and make the next Uber or whatever. So,
um, it is, uh, education
is a big piece of it,
but that you need that support
at the civil level too. You know?
Um, oh, what's the word? You know,
making sure that there's certain land,
um,
agreements that it's not just about
building luxury condos, right?
Cause it's very quick to say
a factory will, you know, uh,
not yield as much from a real estate
perspective than a luxury condo.
But you know, that's not going
to help build a community, uh,
and certainly not help build at
diversity within the community.
Um, and I'm hoping Detroit
has an opportunity and there's
a lot of people working
hard at this to help
build this infrastructure.
Uh, and also if we can make it work
in Detroit, that's a blueprint.
Let's hope to do it in other cities.
But I was one of those kids who grew up
in the factory and I said from a very
young age, I would never work in the
factory. My brothers on the other hand,
did work in the factory, made a
lot more money than I did, um,
got burned when things by the
90s. It was, that was it. Um,
but it's all coming back now.
My brother actually held onto his machines
and now he's his knitting businesses,
getting, he's getting the
phone calls that he, you know,
a lot of people sold their
machines. He happen to hold on. Um,
but I think there's a
huge opportunity there,
but it's going to be a lot of different
entities working together and there
needs to be a huge PR campaign
that the media can help drive, um,
to change the perception.
It's a lot of people in this
room work with cmos every day.
They have to go out and meet and,
and, and provide thoughts, ideas.
I'm sitting there and obviously
you've had a good PR background.
It's helped set you up for a lot of
things here, even handling today.
Could you give them advice and, and, well,
how do you think about when
people come in, you, you know,
you said you talked to your agency about
the ad that was going to run when the
Apple Watch was being announced.
Can you give us any advice for how you,
you think about it or when someone
comes in to talk with you about ideas or
thoughts, how you, how you think of about
things? Um, for me,
I'm always impressed when someone
takes the time to research your brand.
All the information's out there now.
Not all of it accurate,
but there's a lot of sources out there
where you can really educate yourself
about a brand. I mean, even for
people who are, um, interviewing,
I'm often shocked by people who don't
really do their research. And I'm like,
why are you here? You know?
Um, so do your research,
help them realize that you took a moment
to not only understand their brand,
but to understand their business. So,
you know, not only researching Shinola,
but looking at where we
sit in Nordstrom and what,
who's our competitive set and looking
at their business leading up to meeting.
You don't need to become a watch expert.
Um,
but just gathering that information
and bringing that to a meeting to say,
we looked at your business,
we looked at your competitive set and
here's some learnings that we had from an
outside perspective because often you
guys might see something that we don't see
because we're in the thick of it.
Um,
so I think a fresh approach to just the
information that's out there before we
even get to the meeting.
Yeah, good question.
Good.
Detroit is for manufacturing,
also famous for creativity. And, um,
and I wonder if you could speak a little
bit to Detroit's influence and Shinola
designed now and maybe
as you see the future,
especially with some of these world class
leaders in the areas you're going into
being a New York based
as you might expect.
But how is Detroit for House talent?
For us, we're very, from a product
perspective inspired by the architecture.
Uh,
so definitely the architecture of Detroit.
I would say the spirit and the attitude
of Detroit you see in our marketing and
sort of the irreverence of our voice
comes from Detroit and that Detroit versus
everybody. Um, sort of sentiment. Um,
you know,
I do think that in order for Detroit
to really be a player as it was in,
in the global marketplace,
from a creativity innovation standpoint,
it needs to be a place that maintains its,
its talent.
Because often what happens is
the talents here and they leave,
they go to Chicago, they go to New York
because the opportunity isn't here.
So as businesses continue
to grow or move to Detroit,
um, I think that's an opportunity
to get back on in the ranks,
if you will,
of being an innovative city of
being a city that drives creative.
Um, it certainly inspires
us every day. Um,
but I think being able to keep the talent
that comes here is something that we
need to work on.
Um,
I mean the education system as a whole
other thing because if you're a young
person or you know, if you're coming
married with kids, I don't have kids,
so I live in Detroit. I'm not worried
about the education system personally,
but it's a huge problem because,
you know,
I have colleagues of mine that say
I would love to live in Detroit,
but I don't know where to send my kids to
school. So they drive them to, you know,
gross point or whatever after a while.
First of all,
not everyone has access
to do that. Yeah. Um,
so those are things that
are really important.
Just basic things or our public school
system really needs a lot of work in
order to make this an attractive
city for creative people,
for business minded people to live in and
build a family and not have to go live
in the suburbs because I need to be in
a certain zip code to write for their
kids to go to a good school.
Very important.
Any last one last question
from the audience then I'll
close with one. Go ahead.
So this may be a little bit of everywhere,
but I was curious to hear it, uh,
when [inaudible] started,
to what extent was Detroit factored in
as like the only location or was it like
one of several locations
that were considered?
I've heard kind of how price point was
factored into choosing to try it as a
potential location to kind of headquarters
at all. And then part two of that,
as you expand internationally, what
is the recognition of Detroit, uh,
on the international level
and do you think like,
should I know all of that salt is now
going to become a vehicle to help promote
the trait, whereas the tray first
may have promoted Froedtert? Shinola?
It's almost seems like
it's now should I know,
is Turner to promote Detroit
in the international spectrum?
Oh,
we definitely are doing that.
I mean this brand part of our DNA and
what we built this brand on is the fact
that we're in Detroit.
The fact that, you know,
we have a watch factory and
a leather factory in Detroit,
the intention was always at
this would be a global brand.
We didn't know how the Detroit,
um,
name would resonate certainly
outside of Michigan,
but even outside of the u s what
we're finding is people, um,
it's resonating because it's that underdog
story. People want Detroit to win.
There's a Detroit everywhere.
I'm
so sorry. Um, it is resonating.
No, I'm joking. No, it's
funny because I think as we,
as we travel,
many of us travel all over the place
and that we probably all feel that we're
the ones standing up for Detroit.
I know I'm,
whether I'm here or are internationally,
it's,
I get teased a lot. Oh Detroit,
what's happening in Detroit? I'm like,
come on to try it.
It's great.
So I feel like we were off
fill that in a lot of time.
But to answer the price question,
it wasn't really so much prices.
We invested a lot of money to build
the factory and do the training,
which we continue to do.
Um,
and we did not take the tax
incentives that were offered to us.
Certainly it's cheaper to open a factory
in Detroit than it is in the middle of
Manhattan or la.
Um,
but really the opportunity that we saw,
you know,
you had a workforce,
a trained and talented workforce
that we're sitting without jobs.
So we thought we could transfer that
skill and to watch making leather making.
Um, so, sure. Is it cheaper to
open a factory in Detroit? Yes.
I mean that's changing now
with real estate booming
the way that it's doing. Um,
but it wasn't necessarily about the price,
it was about the,
the opportunity and the talent base
that exists here in manufacturing.
And so one last question.
You mentioned Shinola
to be a global brand.
It's only about five years old.
So what are the global brands that are
iconic brands that might be on the wall
or in the thoughts of those
at Shinola to emulate?
You know, we'll even say we poked fun
at them. Apple definitely is up there
and it was all in good
fun. Um, you know, Tesla,
Virgin, um, these are all brands
that, you know, we aspire to.
I think Tesla would probably be number
one on that list. Yeah. Um, you know,
and it's,
it's been amazing to just be a part of
what's happening in Detroit. We're one of,
you guys know how many people that are
working both small and large scale like
Dan Gilbert, to really help
bring the city back on its feet.
And my hope is that it continues
to be a place of equal opportunity.
That it doesn't just become my,
my lovely New York,
but million dollar plus,
you know,
condos that most people can't
afford. Uh, cause it really starts,
it really hurts a city when it
becomes homogeneous like that.
So you have to make sure there's
a balance of opportunity, um,
that maintains the diversity.
Um,
that's the one thing that I think New
York lost over the years because now you
turn around everywhere you go.
I mean, bedstuy which, you know,
I remember growing up as a kid in
Brooklyn, you just didn't go there.
And now it's like luxury
apartment buildings and
townhouses all over the place.
Yeah. So, and that's going to
keep the creativity here as well.
Well, we want to thank you for your
time. We know how busy you are out.
We have a little gift for you.
And um,
thank you for being part of our first
talks at Google in the Birmingham office.
So thank you for
[inaudible].